[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON ANDREAS: Please welcome
to Google Detroit, Mrs. Kristi
Hedges.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, thank you
again for joining us.
We appreciate it.
I mentioned in the bio intro--
so you wrote a book previously
called "The Power of Presence."
KRISTI HEDGES: Right.
JASON ANDREAS: And this book is
called "The Inspiration Code."
Are you able of kick things
off by just telling us
a little bit about how those
two things or those two books
are similar and perhaps
how they're different?
Presence versus inspiration--
they tie together.
But there's obviously
differences between them.
Maybe kick things off with that,
and then, we'll go from there.
KRISTI HEDGES: Yeah, sure.
So, let me start by saying how
I ended up writing this book.
JASON ANDREAS: Absolutely.
KRISTI HEDGES:
Because that's how
they're kind of tied together.
JASON ANDREAS: Sure.
KRISTI HEDGES: So I wrote
"The Power of Presence,"
and it came out in 2011.
And that's really a
book about influence.
How do we use our presence to
influence situations around us?
And as I was out talking
to groups about that,
I would start by asking
them this simple question
to warm up the audience a
little bit, get people talking.
And that was, who inspired
you, and what did they do?
And I was trying to
map those answers
and those characteristics
back to people
who had presence and
made this real life
connection for people.
Well, what I noticed when
I asked that question,
pretty immediately
it was-- no matter
how tired people
were-- maybe it's
the day after a holiday
weekend or something like that.
When they would start talking
about these people who
inspired them, their
faces would light up.
And there would be
all this animation
and energy in the room.
And people would be
literally transformed
energetically in front of
me, and that happened again
and again and again and again.
And people would talk as part
of the exercise about what
these people did.
And I noticed that they
communicated in certain ways
that inspired people.
I mean, to even
remember things--
and you guys have them now.
Somebody said something to you
that just hit you just right.
And those words, you
carry them around.
And you use them
when you need them.
And they fortify you when
you need guidance and all
those kind of good things.
And I just started writing
down, what did these people do?
And I found that these patterns
emerged again and again.
And that led me to
put them together
in "The Inspiration Code."
But as I looked at those--
because I was usually
there speaking to groups
to talk about presence,
to talk about influence,
which is really important.
But what we-- in leadership
development programs,
we often rely so
much on influence
that we leave out this other
piece about engagement,
which is inspiration.
And if you think about that, we
need both of them as leaders,
but they go hand-in-hand.
I mean, none of us go home
after a day of work and say,
I had such a great day today.
I was influenced all day long.
I mean that-- it
feels different.
Influence is done to us.
But we would go home and
say, I was so inspired today.
I had a great day.
Inspiration comes from within.
So I really wanted to
figure how to create
those feelings in
people in the workplace,
because we need more of it.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah, absolutely.
You-- so one of the really
interesting things that I read
about in the book
is this kind of--
the quiet influence
of listening.
So we talk about inspiration.
And when do you think about
an inspirational person,
you think of a great speaker
or somebody with presence.
One of the things you
mentioned, though,
was one of the most cited
behaviors of somebody who
is inspiring is the
ability to listen.
Can you talk a little
bit more about that?
It seems like a
simple thing, right?
Listening-- everyone
should be able to do it.
But it's not really that
easy of a concept to handle.
A lot of people aren't
good at listening.
You talk about how listening
plays into inspiration
and also how we can work on
becoming better listeners
in order to be more
inspirational with the folks
that we lead.
KRISTI HEDGES: Yeah, that
was a surprise to me.
So as part of the
research that I did,
I also did quantitative research
that I commissioned on my own.
And I looked at, what
are the behaviors that
were most impactful to people
in terms of inspiration?
And the number one
behavior was listening.
And I also heard in these
discussions people would say,
that person was there for me.
They made time for me.
They were focused on me.
That came up again
and again and again.
So it was clear
that there was just
something magical about when
somebody creates a space for us
through strong listening skills.
So whether you're in sales or
whether you're leading teams,
when we listen to
people, it's a sign
of respect for their opinion.
It's a sign that we care.
There is a great quote that,
"The currency of love is time."
And I would say the currency
of respect is attention.
So when we give people our
attention, it feels different.
But we're not very good
listeners as a group.
We learned to listen
quick and listen halfway,
so we get done what
we need to get done.
And that's why when somebody
really listens to us,
it's like the record skips that
it just feels quite different.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah.
And I think another concept
you talked about too
is authenticity.
KRISTI HEDGES: Mm-hmm.
JASON ANDREAS: We've
all encountered leaders
who most likely read
a leadership book,
and that's pretty much it.
But there's no
authenticity to it,
because they're just
spitting back something
that they read about
being a powerful speaker
or giving somebody
a strong handshake.
That doesn't necessarily
equate to authentic leadership.
It's just something they
read about in a look--
in a book.
And I think listening is
one of those aspects that
actually conveys authenticity.
Can you talk about this concept
of authenticity as well?
Not just reading a
book about leadership
and spitting it back
to your employees,
but how you actually can become
an authentic leader in addition
to the listening that we talked
about-- some other concepts
around that.
KRISTI HEDGES: Yeah,
well I mean, listening--
I mean authenticity really is--
it's about trust when
it comes down to it.
You know, we trust
people who are real.
So if we don't feel like
we actually know someone,
then it's very difficult for
us to really invest in them.
But authenticity
is tricky at work.
People can be too
authentic as well.
So it's just trying
to figure out
with that fine line
is of you're authentic
enough so that we know you.
And yet, you're also
aware of your surroundings
and what the situation
will support.
And so with
authenticity what I--
what I often will tell people
is that we have to-- it really
has to start within you.
What is your intention for
what you want to get across?
And being very clear about what
I call your personal presence
brand, which is really your
values worn on the outside.
How do I want to show up?
How do I want people
to perceive me?
How do I want to show
what's most important to me?
If you're very clear
about that going in,
then you're much
more likely for that
to come out in an authentic
way, because it really
is about the core of who you
want to be in that situation.
But situational
awareness matters too,
so also knowing what those--
the rule of support, because
sometimes we get into too--
you get too much information,
the TMI situation,
where, whoa, your authenticity
is screaming at me here.
[INAUDIBLE] kind
of back it back up.
JASON ANDREAS: So when
we talk about TMI,
sometimes emotion comes
into-- to the discussion
as well in terms of
leadership and authenticity.
Google is known for coming up
with this concept of Search
Inside Yourself, which is this
concept based on mindfulness
and emotion within
the workplace.
And not a lot of companies were
really thinking about this.
Like, how does this play
into kind of the ecosystem
of the workplace?
But I think it's
a core-- emotion
is a core aspect of
leadership that a lot of folks
don't necessarily grasp.
How do you-- how do you
tie emotion into leadership
without being
unauthentic-- like,
how do you do it in a way
that displays sincerity?
Can you talk a little
bit about the importance
of mindfulness or emotion within
the aspects of leadership?
KRISTI HEDGES: Yeah, well the--
I just wrote a piece for a
"Harvard Business Review,"
which is, I believe,
going online this week,
called, "Go Ahead.
Get Emotional at Work."
And--
JASON ANDREAS: Perfect.
Perfect timing.
KRISTI HEDGES: And
the idea was the fact
that in my world with coaching
and leaders that I coach,
it's not that people are
bringing too much emotion in.
They're not bringing
enough emotion in.
And emotion is really
a signal for us.
It's a trigger to understand
really what you care about.
So if a leader comes in
and they're overly stoic,
it's like what's there?
Knock, knock, knock.
You're looking for what
with the real story is.
And so emotion is
actually something
we want to be very
strategic about as leaders.
Because if we want
people to feel something,
we have to bring it.
So if I want people
to get excited,
I have to bring
excitement into a room.
If I want people
to feel serious,
I have to bring
seriousness into a room.
So knowing what emotion
you're trying to impart
and instead of trying to either
have it be an afterthought,
to make it really important
part of your communication
is really what that's about.
So it's knowing
what that emotion is
and then being willing
to put it out there.
And instead of--
lot of us come up
through the ranks
learning that we
want to be unemotional at work.
We don't want to show.
We want to be always stoic,
have the same demeanor
no matter what
people throw at us.
And as an individual
contributor,
we get rewarded for that.
And we're told, oh, gosh,
you can give Jason anything.
He's gonna-- he always has a
smile on his face no matter
what you dump on his lap.
JASON ANDREAS: It's
very true, yeah.
KRISTI HEDGES: And then
you get to be a leader,
and that doesn't
work so well anymore.
Because you have to use
emotion to get people excited,
to make them feel something,
and being able to actually think
about, oh, gosh, how should
I be emotional at work
versus not having
emotion be something
that we really think about.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah I
feel like we-- sometimes
at Google-- encounter
the opposite of that
as well, though,
where when you're
an individual contributor--
an individual contributor
or you're newer to the company,
you bring more emotion.
You're like, oh, I'm at Google.
This is exciting.
People are more emotional.
They're more emotional
in their interactions
with their managers.
But then as you progress and you
become part of the leadership
team-- maybe you're a
manager, or you manage a team,
or you're a director--
you feel like you have to be
more serious and more stoic.
And you actually
remove the emotion,
because you want to be
respected and authoritative
versus an individual contributor
that's a little bit more
free and open.
Do you see that as well as being
a concept that comes across
in inspiration
where when folks get
into a position of
leadership, they actually
lose some of those
traits of a good leader,
because they feel
they have to based
on maybe an antiquated
vision of what a leader is.
KRISTI HEDGES:
Yeah, well, exactly.
And that's why I love that
example where people come in,
and they're like all gung-ho.
And as a leader, they're
like let's tamp-- let's tamp
that down.
Gosh, we don't want our
leaders to be excited.
JASON ANDREAS: Exactly, yeah.
KRISTI HEDGES: And it's kind
of funny as we talk about it.
But you see that
play out, there's--
as you say that, it just-- it
makes me think about how we
think about-- we equate joy--
joyfulness at work with naivete.
And that doesn't
serve us very well.
Because wouldn't it be great to
have leaders who are actually
joyful about the
work that they did
versus coming in and feeling
like it's a grind every day?
That doesn't inspire anybody.
So it's really
thinking-- again, we
don't think about things on
an emotional plane very much.
But if you just think
about it as a leader
and play around with
the idea of emotion
as being a critical part
of how you communicate,
that opens up a lot that maybe
we don't even think we have.
JASON ANDREAS: Sure.
Can you talk-- kind of tying
that topic together too--
so your book talks a lot
about inspiring others.
Can you maybe turn
that inward a bit
and talk about how
leaders of folks
here in the room, folks that are
watching who are in positions
of influence or leadership,
how they can inspire themselves
from a leadership perspective?
How can they-- if maybe they're
one of these more stoic leaders
and something just--
the last comment you made--
something snapped them.
They said, hey, wait.
I'm one of these stoic leaders.
How can I inspire myself to be
a little bit more joyful, more
mindful, more emotional at work?
What are some practices
or ways that folks
who are in a position
of leadership
can inspire themselves?
KRISTI HEDGES: Well, everything
that I wrote in the book
that inspires other
people also inspires you.
And I'll be honest,
that didn't even hit me
until the end of the book.
So I was writing it.
And I'm, wait a minute.
We can use these
things on ourselves.
And that's great, because
that--that's the idea.
It's a virtuous cycle.
So when we inspire other
people, we also get inspired.
And it-- and it all plays
into the same thing.
But for example,
one of the top ways
that-- we were saying
that earlier-- that people
get inspired is
through conversation,
through communication
with other people.
You can get inspired
reading your email,
but you probably won't.
It's probably-- it's
sitting like this,
listening to other people
talk, thinking about things.
And I know you guys do a lot
of that Google-- bringing ideas
in from the outside just to
expand your mind a little bit
and get you to
think differently.
And so with leaders that
I've worked with often,
they'll get to a
place where they've
achieved a great
level of success,
but they just don't feel all
that inspired anymore about it.
And then I'll ask, well, who
do you talk to during the day?
And they talk to
the same people.
They talk to their
management team.
They might go out and
talk to some customers.
Occasionally, they talk to the
board, whatever the case is.
But they don't actually have
any new inputs coming in.
And so to really go out
and seek inspiration
to find people to
have conversations
with to-- if you don't have
any role models, to find some.
Because they might not be
sitting around the office.
You might have to
look outward for that.
And to put yourself in
places that just really
help you open your mind can be
a great pathway to inspiration.
JASON ANDREAS: Sure.
You speak-- obviously,
you're here at Google today.
You speak to a lot
of other companies.
You speak at schools.
You speak at businesses.
Are there any really
interesting techniques
that you've absorbed
from speaking
at these different places--
folks that are doing,
I guess, either, A,
really great job of
inspiring their employees,
or their students, or
whatever it may be;
or on the flip side, B,
doing a really poor job
and doing it maybe in a forceful
way or an inauthentic way as we
discussed earlier.
KRISTI HEDGES: Well, I'll tell
you something that I see a lot.
So I don't-- and I'm not
calling out anybody in this.
If you see yourself in
this, then there you go.
Is that companies spent
a lot of money and time
on corporate mission statements
and corporate visions.
And it's not that they don't
matter, because they do matter.
They just don't matter enough.
And they don't look at, what
are the conversations that
are happening every day in
organizations between managers
and their people and teams?
And what is the--
I would say the
cultures are really
just stories built upon
stories in the organization.
There aren't enough
fresh stories
getting into the mix about
things that are working
and things that--
solutions that are
being overcome.
And so they really hang their
hat on this beautiful mission
statement.
And yet, everybody
in the organization
doesn't buy it, because the
culture doesn't support it.
So I see a lot of
that where we look
at the very high level, the-- so
the grand ideas of inspiration.
And we've heard that you
have to have a great vision.
So we check that box,
and we spend a lot
of money checking that box.
And then we just wait for
everybody's behavior to change.
And it doesn't really
get embedded down
to the individual level.
I mean, what inspires us is
our day-to-day interactions
with people around us.
JASON ANDREAS: Sure.
What are some common
mistakes people make?
We've talked a lot about
the positive things
that people can do.
We've talked about
inauthenticity
as maybe, I guess, a mistake.
But are there other
things that you
see people making on a daily,
monthly, weekly basis--
mistakes that good leadership
folks that should know better
are actually making
mistakes that we
can understand and avoid
learning from past mistakes,
I suppose?
KRISTI HEDGES: Yeah.
Yeah, sure.
Well, it's one we just
talked about at lunch.
And I'll just bring
it up, because it's
very, very current--
is that one of the most
inspiring conversations
a leader can have
is to be in talks
with their people about their
teams, about their purpose.
So helping them
really identify, how
is your purpose for
yourself being played out
and being supported in the--
in the position that you're in?
And that seems like a
really grand conversation,
but it doesn't have to be.
So just talking about
contextualized purpose--
so how does what
you're doing today
just help you take
a couple of steps
further along in
your development?
It can be that simple.
But often, managers don't want
to be in that conversation,
because they're worried
that's going to have some--
their-- team member is
going to have an epiphany
and then go out
the door with that.
And so they don't
want that to happen.
So like, well, I'm not going to
have that purpose conversation,
because I might lose them.
And that's a real
missed opportunity.
Because first of all, we
love when people engage us
in that larger question.
Because we're thinking
about it, or we
want to be thinking about it.
And if somebody creates a space
for us, it's very meaningful.
And then also, often
there are things
that you don't see that
somebody around you
might see that can pull some
threads together and help you
understand that--
let's say you're
working into a company
that's very chaotic.
Well, that chaos might
be really teaching you
how to manage a
lot of complexity,
which you're going to need for
the next level of your career.
So if somebody can help you
see that, all of a sudden,
that chaotic environment
isn't a grind just
to manage through every day.
It's a huge learning
opportunity.
And you may not
see that yourself.
So being willing to be
in those conversations
is quite powerful, and we
don't have them enough.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah.
Often times, people
want to build
on the base of what they have
without analyzing that base.
So they're-- how can
I be more inspiring?
I'll do A, B, and C
without fixing what
was wrong in the first place.
So we often look at how
you can improve upon what
you're currently doing.
And then, once you feel
like you've fixed that base,
then you proceed
with some of the tips
from the book in terms of how
you can inspire and become
better yourself.
A lot of the book talks
in context of inspiring
in a corporate setting.
Are there ways that you can
take a lot of these topics
and themes and apply them
outside of the corporate world
as well?
KRISTI HEDGES: Yes.
I mean, everything
in the book works
in any environment you're in.
So I have found myself
starting to use these
at home with my kids a lot
more as I've done the research.
JASON ANDREAS: That's
what I'm asking, yeah.
KRISTI HEDGES: This might work.
Let me think about that.
And it's great.
They do.
And so it doesn't matter if
you're trying to-- there's
a lot of inspiration going
on in communities right now.
There' a lot of inspiration
going on in Detroit right now.
And so using these
kinds of ideas
about what really gets people
inspired, what lights up--
lights people up-- it's
any group you can imagine.
It's your teams at work.
It's your communities at home.
It's your schools that
you're working in.
It doesn't matter.
It's the same stuff, which
is the beauty of it, right?
I love when things apply
at work and apply at home.
And that's really what I tried
to do last time with "The Power
of Presence" too.
It doesn't really matter
where you have presence.
It's all the same result.
JASON ANDREAS: We talked
a little bit-- right
before we hopped on
stage here-- about how
inspiration can be contagious.
And we talked about
the city of Detroit,
which we're all
located in right now,
and how Detroit has
seen better days.
But what happened was there
was a few inspired individuals
who started to apply inspiration
to a certain-- their house,
to a neighborhood, a
street, whatever it may be.
And it spread very quickly.
We saw this inspiration
spread very quickly.
And I feel like
that same concept--
this took place in
a major US city.
That same concept can also
be applied to the workplace.
So if you're in an
uninspired workplace, having
a few individuals
that bring inspiration
that learn how to be
inspiring individuals,
that could catch on.
And it could be
contagious as well, right?
KRISTI HEDGES: Absolutely And I
sit here with my Shinola watch
on.
So it's supporting Detroit.
JASON ANDREAS: Beautiful.
Beautiful.
KRISTI HEDGES: And
I-- we were saying,
I've been lurking,
watching Detroit for years
and just rooting for
Detroit and just so inspired
by what's happening here.
So there is actually a
scientifically researched,
well-researched theory
called emotional contagion.
And so we always think about
it just in layman's terms
as, you catch
somebody's bad mood.
Don't bring people down.
Debbie Downer, we catch people's
bad or whatever the case is.
But it is actually verifiable.
As humans, we do pick up
the moods of other people.
And we develop as groups
what sociologists call group
affect, which is we kind of--
we kind of go towards the
center of whatever the mood is
in a particular organization.
Now, leaders actually
have more power
to shift that mood
than anybody else,
because people may pay
more attention to leaders.
We pay attention
up the hierarchy.
So if a leader is cynical, the
group's going to feel cynical.
If the leader is optimistic,
we're going to feel optimistic.
And so absolutely,
it is contagious.
But you need those people to
come in and be the brave ones
to be the beachhead
for whatever emotion
it is that you're trying
to get people to impart.
And of course, there's
safety in numbers.
So if you get a few
people really excited,
then that tends to
change the dynamic
of a much larger organization.
But it has to start
with somebody.
JASON ANDREAS: Sure.
And we talked about in the
city of Detroit, Dan Gilbert--
not by far, not the only
person, but obviously,
one of the figureheads of some
positivity around Detroit.
And he instilled a lot
of inspiration in people
by investing a lot of
his money into the city.
And again, a lot of
people, when they
saw that happen, a lot of
folks who were outside the city
or in the city who hadn't
necessarily invested,
now are investing
time and money to help
have inspire the city as well.
So Dan Gilbert's one that
comes to mind in Detroit.
Do you have any other leaders
that are inspiring to you--
folks that--
either in your home town,
or folks in your industry,
other authors that
have really embraced
this idea of inspiration and
presence and authenticity--
folks that have
really inspired you?
KRISTI HEDGES: Well, I'm
in Washington, DC, so--
[LAUGHING]
JASON ANDREAS: Lots
of inspiration there.
KRISTI HEDGES: There's
a lot of inspiration,
all kinds of different ways.
Yes.
So, yes, I get inspired
by people all the time.
And I'll just tell you
personally for me right now,
I'm quite inspired by
people who are maybe
20 years further along in
their career than I am.
Because I'm starting
to look and think, OK,
this next phase of my life--
how can I be most inspiring
in that and use my talents
and do the things
that I think are going
to be important beyond myself?
And I'm very inspired by people
who have been there before.
And role modeling is
just-- it's such a huge--
we talked about it earlier too.
Role models are inspiring
to us, because they create
a vicarious experience for us.
When we see somebody,
like Dan Gilbert,
come in and do that, we're
inspired because we see
him do something,
and we think, well, I
could maybe do that too.
So maybe I can't buy
a whole building,
but maybe I could put a couple
of my people in that building.
So we make another step.
And that's what role
models do for us.
So I'm really looking
at people who are--
have a real need and
energy around being
in service and then how they're
doing that in their lives.
And so I am lucky enough
to have a couple of people
that I sought out, because
they didn't land in my lap.
And I try to spend time with
them, and I see what they do.
And I always leave those
conversations just 10
feet tall, and we need that.
We need those people.
JASON ANDREAS: Absolutely.
We're going to shifting
topics a little bit,
but still kind of tying into
what we were just talking about
is the idea of diversity.
So diversity-- not in the
sense of what people look like
or where they're from, but
the diversity of cultures,
diversity of backgrounds,
diversity of professional
experience-- is incredibly
important and a huge topic--
incredibly important
for Google, a huge topic
in the media these days.
How do you tie this
idea of diversity
into authentic leadership
and inspiration and presence?
Is there a way to tie-in what
you were just mentioning,
bringing in diversity
from other folks
and really bringing that
all together in a way that
makes sense for a company, or a
family, or whatever it may be?
KRISTI HEDGES: I don't know.
But I'll try.
[LAUGHING] Let me see if I can.
JASON ANDREAS: We're all
trying right now, of course.
KRISTI HEDGES:
Well, the research
supports that diverse
organizations perform better.
We know that at the board
level, throughout organizations.
I believe that the reason
that that's the case
is because of the
input idea that I just
talked about with inspiration.
When we see things from
people's experience,
it just expands our
own perspective.
So whatever cultural
blinders we have--
and you can define
culture however you want--
they get widened when we see
things that we previously
didn't see, because somebody
else has helped us see that.
We've-- whether through role
modeling, or being with them,
or discussion, or
whatever the case is--
so we learn a lot more.
People become three-dimensional
when they're in front of us
and we know them and we can--
we understand that more.
We're a global world.
It's a trite phrase,
but it's true.
We work with people--
I work with people
all over the world.
You guys probably do the same.
And so diversity of
everything is important,
because it just allows us
to be in the world and--
with a broader perspective.
JASON ANDREAS: Sure.
Perspectives are huge.
Getting perspectives from
different people and countries
and everything, cultures--
a huge difference maker.
What's one piece of
advice you would give us,
as Google-- speaking
to us as Google today
in terms of inspiration?
Is there anything
you've heard or read
that we do good or bad
that could potentially
be turned into advice
that we could walk with--
walk away with today?
KRISTI HEDGES: Well, Google is
known for a lot of the things
that we just talked about.
So you guys are lucky,
because you're sitting
in organizations like that.
And not all of the organizations
I work with can say the same.
What I admire from
Google from afar--
so I don't work in the company.
But what I-- what
I see is just the--
you mentioned work
curiosity before.
But that's what I see.
I see just a hunger
and a curiosity
to learn and expand
and try new things.
And when you have that
permeating the culture--
even today-- so we're
having a Google Talk.
We talked about earlier--
I said you're in a [INAUDIBLE]
Because you help put these
together, that
means that you get
to learn a lot about things that
you might be-- you care about.
But all Google has
that opportunity.
So I think having that
kind of mindset and to be--
to be an outspoken leader in
things that from a business
standpoint in the corporate
community, which Google
does frequently, is inspiring
to a lot of other organizations.
And you see that.
You see there are a select
number of companies--
and Google's one of
them-- that can put out
a pretty bold statement.
And you see other companies
lining up behind them.
And there's a
responsibility with that.
But Google seems to
take it pretty well.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah.
Well, we do our best.
We do our best to be
inspirational as a company
and as individual contributors
here in the city of Detroit.
But it's hard.
It's a simple concept, but
putting it into practice, is--
it takes-- it does
take practice itself.
It takes practice
and understanding
and cognizance
more than anything.
I wanted to open up now--
I'm sure we've got some
questions from the audience.
We have a lot of leadership
here in the room.
Wanted to open it
up for questions
if anyone has any questions
that we can ask Kristi.
I do have mics here
if you want to--
Corey, if you don't mind
running those for us.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'll break
the ice for you, Jason.
Hi, Dave Hoffman.
And this is one of my
topics close to my heart.
I went back to get
my MBA specifically
based on corporate
cultures, things like that.
I am an ex-athlete,
and it's always funny
how the best team
doesn't always win.
It's normally the team that has
the most heart, the most-- best
leadership, inspiration,
all those kind of things.
One of the things
that I've found time
and time again is that natural--
like that God-given
brilliance seems
to really hinder your ability
to be an inspirational leader.
You get so caught up in how
things work or your mind
and whatever, that
you tend to not be
as personable or as outgoing.
And that seems to be
the case sometimes here
at Google, where we
lack a little bit
of inspirational
leadership, because they
just that EQ isn't there.
So first, what are some of the
traits where you can actually
help coach someone up into that
from a leadership perspective?
Or the other end
of the spectrum,
where somebody might
be a little bit more
fast and loose-- so a lot of
energy, but at the same time
needs to find a way to
authentically dial it back
down so that they can fit
into that mold of a leader
without losing their uniqueness
or their genuineness.
KRISTI HEDGES: Sure.
That's a couple of questions.
But I like where you're going.
And let me just say
that athletes often--
people who are former
athletes or athletes often
really get this,
because a lot of it
is-- starts on the
inside, the mental game--
so really being
clear about that.
And if you have been an
athlete, a lot of times--
I wasn't an athlete.
I've heard this.
That that's a part
of the training.
Or it's a positive visualization
plays a big role in it.
So I'm not surprised to hear
the connection that you just
made between the
athleticism and then--
and culture.
So the being in your head
problem's an interesting one.
It's a blessing and a curse.
Because often if we're someone
who spends a lot of time
conceptualizing-- and maybe
that's our personality,
or maybe we're an introvert
and that's how we process,
or whatever the case--
it means that our first instinct
might not be to communicate.
Our first instinct is to
step back and think about it.
And when I work with
leaders like that--
which I do all the time, because
a lot of people are introverts
and that's where
they naturally go--
it's to get them out
of that predisposition
that things have to be perfect
before I communicate it.
And so I'm thinking
of someone that I
worked with several years ago.
And so one of my pieces
of advice to him was,
you need to-- you
need to go for--
intentional transparency
is what I called it.
Because you think that
people are reading your mind.
But no one knows what's
going on up in here.
And so you need to be
very intentional about it.
So your first instinct when you
get a new piece of information
or when you have a plan
that's maybe 50% baked,
not 100% baked,
is to tell people.
You need to get that
knee-jerk reaction.
Because if it's just
you thinking about it,
then it doesn't
really shape anything.
So that's one thing that
comes up quite a bit if that--
if that makes sense.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
KRISTI HEDGES: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
KRISTI HEDGES: Mm-hmm.
JASON ANDREAS: Cool.
Other questions?
Ashley.
AUDIENCE: I'm gonna--
AUDIENCE: Hot mic.
Here we go.
How's this?
Better?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK, great.
So in addition to
being an author,
you consult and work
with large companies.
And so I'm sitting here thinking
about all these principles
and how we might push them down
through a company like Google
or through one of the
companies that we support
in this room, which are
large auto makers-- a GM,
a Ford, a Chrysler.
So when you think about
tackling a huge corporate client
like that-- let's say budget
was no option-- no issue,
and the CEO said,
I need your help
transforming my leadership.
What are-- what are some
of the levers or the tools
that you would use
with the company,
and what do you think
would be required to really
push this type of
inspirational development
through a large organization?
Is it everything from personal
coaching for their leaders
in addition to retreats?
And what are the levers that
you use to help actually
push this through
in a meaningful way
across a big organization?
KRISTI HEDGES: OK.
Well, first of all,
no one ever says,
you can have all
the money you want.
[LAUGHING]
But my brain went
[SHOOTING NOISES]
Well, so a couple
things-- obviously,
I'm a big believer in coaching.
So I think there is
something really powerful.
And I became a coach
because I had a coach.
And it just changed--
he changed my life.
And so I wanted to be able to
offer that to other people.
And hopefully-- I don't know
if I changed their lives,
but I try really hard to be--
to be in service of them.
Is that personal
coaching changes things,
because it's just such a
unique development opportunity.
It's so personalized.
And it really allows
you to ask the questions
that you want to ask in a very
safe setting with someone who
isn't invested in your outcome.
They just want you
to be successful.
So nobody is trying
to game the system.
So that's why I think
coaching is very effective.
But beyond that, if I could
work in an organization
however I wanted to, what
I think is most effective
is when you introduce
concepts to a swath of people.
So maybe it's all
leaders in a office
or whatever the case is--
so everybody gets the same
songbook, if you will.
So everybody starts to
think about things a little
differently.
And then you have some breakout
cohort groups underneath
of that.
Because I think-- back
to the role modeling
and the conversation--
I that's what
really starts to get
people to think, OK, how can
I really embed this in my day
to day?
And you get economies
of scale that way,
because the conversation
gets richer.
And everybody gets
curious, and they
start looking at other things.
So I think it's a combination
of those that can really
help shift the culture.
But let me just
say that anything
that I wrote about in this
book or the last book,
I always tell people this.
It's not hard stuff.
It's not like you read, and
you're like, wow, listening--
I never thought about
listening before.
You know it.
We just don't do it.
And so part of my
work, what I try to do,
is really to close
that knowing-doing gap.
So you know it, but then
how do you make it easier
to actually just do it?
And so I try to make it
very accessible for people.
And so when I come in
and work with teams,
that's really what it's about.
I'm not there to
tell you something
you've never heard before.
I'm there to get
you to do things
you probably know
you already should
be doing but you don't do.
And that's really what it is.
JASON ANDREAS: Sometimes
it's good to have a reminder.
For folks in this room
and folks across Google,
you talk about it.
These concepts
are not difficult.
They're simple concepts.
It's not rocket science.
But a lot of times to some
folks in a company like this,
coding search algorithms
is very simple.
Listening, actually, is
not that simple for them.
It's something that
they do have to practice
and something that seems
like a very simple concept
but outside of what
they're used to is--
it takes a little bit of
extra focus and elbow grease
to make sure that
it happens right.
[INAUDIBLE] the last question
I had because you mentioned
is here.
And the answer to Ashley's
question was around coaching.
And you mentioned that you had
a coach yourself that drove you
in the right direction.
Can you talk about that
process a little bit?
Because we all-- we
talk about inspiration.
We're talking about presence.
I think one thing
that we all look
for here is finding coaches
that can help us along our paths
as well to become better
inspirational leaders,
to become better employees,
and things like that.
Can you talk about that
coaching and coachee atmosphere
that you just mentioned and talk
a little bit about your coach
and how that person
has inspired you?
KRISTI HEDGES: Sure.
Well, I-- I've been an
entrepreneur since I was 27.
So I didn't have an organization
full of people to role model
and mentor me.
And very early on,
I got introduced
to someone who was a leadership
coach for small business
owners, and it
was just immensely
helpful in so many ways.
But probably the most
is that it was somebody
I could be very frank with.
And he had a business
for 20 or 30 years.
And so there wasn't
anything I came up
with that he hadn't already
been through it five times.
So it was really
nice just to have
a little bit of normalizing
of things that were happening
but also somebody that could
really just push my thinking
and have just no BS allowed in
the discussion, who would just
call you on stuff
and really make
you accountable but in
a very supportive way.
And that's just a
very unusual dynamic
to have somebody
who will push you,
support you at the same
time, has experience
they can bring that help you
understand contextually what's
going on, and then doesn't
have any gain in your outcome.
So they're not going to fire
you if you don't do it--
what you just talked about.
It's really you.
It's your development
opportunity.
You do what you
want to do with it.
And I find with my
clients now as a coach,
my job is to be supportive.
And my job is to be
incredibly honest.
So I don't hold back
with my clients.
I think they need to hear
what my observations are.
That's what I'm there for.
And I try to really adjust
to their learning styles
so they can hear
in the best way.
But my investment is in
their success, and that's it.
And I think the best
coaches look at it that way.
JASON ANDREAS: Absolutely.
Great.
Awesome.
Well, Kristi, thank you so
much for coming in today.
We appreciate it.
This was very inspiring
for us, appropriately.
Again, the book, "The
Inspiration Code,"
if you guys haven't, grab
a copy on the way out.
I think it's not out yet.
KRISTI HEDGES: No.
It comes out on Thursday.
JASON ANDREAS: It
comes our on Thursday.
So we have advance copies.
How great is that?
So if you haven't, grab a book.
You can read it before
the general public even
gets to put their hands on it.
So once again, thank
you, Kristi, for coming.
We appreciate it.
Thanks for joining us.
KRISTI HEDGES: Thanks, guys.
Thanks for having me.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]